thor ragnarok released some deleted
scenes this week the blu-ray for Thor
Ragnar came out and a bunch of bonus
goodies came along with it including
yeah all the deleted scenes that show
the interesting alternate angles of
directors the director almost went with
in this movie so let's do a rundown of
all these scenes and discuss how they
would have changed this film okay the
first change involves the sequence with
Thor and dr. strange and Odin's death
now originally strange was just gonna
screw around a lot more with or like
making a key pop out of his mouth that
would free Loki who rather than just
like falling through another dimension
for 30 minutes
strange trapped him inside a port-a-john
so that key is how how Thor coulda got
him out but also strange shows Thor a
map of New York City pointing out the
location of his father who in this
version was disguised as a homeless man
you may have seen some set photos before
the reshoots happened they look like a
glass
yeah but then Odin's death and this
whole confrontation of hello was going
to happen in New York alley as we saw
actually in the initial trailer for the
movie before this was changed
director Taika Waititi moved all of this
to Norway because you know he wanted a
not-it's death to have more meaning and
more emotion behind it Norway of course
is the birthplace of North's mythology
which is the origin of all these
characters so that involved rewriting
and reshooting reconfiguring all of
Odin's death and hellas arrival on this
cliffside field in Norway and
reconfiguring the part of dr. Strange's
scene that you know moved into that but
let's move on to another one next there
was originally going to be a lot more
footage of the cruise escape from us a
car and the return to Asgard there's
gonna be a lot more from the chases
people like arguing aboard the ship also
in the final cut the trip through the
temples anus wormhole it happens
relatively quickly it's almost like
lights up lights lights and lights up
but a deleted scene shows Thor and
banner hanging out on the ship they
they're not what you're seeing there is
is the Grandmaster a sex tape hologram
where
interacting with some alien creature but
they have arms and these like blue socks
that originally gonna be swapped out
later for like tentacles I assume and
he's like making out with him it's
pretty awesome meanwhile banner and Thor
are discussing like the pressure towards
feeling with this like family dynamics
and banner actually compares them to
Dumbo you know like Dumbo had the magic
feather but he never needed it was
inside him all along same with like
Thor's hammer he doesn't need it to be
powerful he's not the god of hammers
he's a god of thunder it's a really good
scene yeah it's pretty great and live
then of course it ends with banner
suddenly realizing he's not eating like
ramen noodles there he's gross though
there's some kind of xenomorph looking
tentacle thing that he's eating and he
swats away and Valkyrie just comes in
and like munches on it she's a badass
she's awesome
there's also a few other scenes I would
describe as you know kind of internal
but they're super fun a chase between
Hulk and Thor through the streets it's a
car some pretty funny riffing by the
Grand Master topaz over like hand
gestures and whether some are universal
what they mean and there was a brief
moment where scourge spots Heimdall
escaping with the Asgardian citizens and
kind of let some escape it was something
that would probably be foreshadowing his
later moment of redemption on the bridge
okay well finally the deleted scenes
include a one short amazing cameo by
yondu Michael Rooker from guardians of
the galaxy it was a moment scourge
scourge is about to execute an innocent
Asgardian whim woman and then yondu
steps out of the crowd and says stop and
then he said instead of sleeping the
woman he just wanted to know where where
the offices of Kevin and Lou are
referring to Kevin studio or to Marvel
studio co-presidents Kevin Feige and
Louie despedido and then when he's point
in the right direction he just walks off
and looking scourge to Coe about his
business killing this woman it's pretty
great
now it's really where it's breaking it's
kind of a jokey thing yeah he died at
the end of guardians the galaxy vol 2
and clearly that took place years before
Thor or dove so I think they maybe had
this as like a joke and they're like
wait he's dead or maybe they shot it
before they knit well maybe they didn't
I already heard the angry nerds what do
we do right they're like oh it's not
gonna work cuz I mean if you think about
it's just like almost like Bugs Bunny
walking into frame and making a joke
okay well let us know what you think
about these deleted scenes in the
comments below
would you prefer Doe Dan's death in the
previous way or
you've used even more Goldblum yeah
right the answer is yeah we could always
use more of them always oh yeah and as a
reminder to follow us on Twitter and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of all your favourite Marvel
movies thanks everybody